jeff has been on a tear all week mad
that you're not picking up on him I do
pick up on him and it's it's just him
complaining that I don't pick up on him
it's getting old
there's no new topic well that's the
worst part Howard is when he has a topic
the topic is usually worse than the
complaining well let's find out what he
was calling for were like what day you
know tell him to pick it and he had
something to say what was it alright
Jeff you're on you know I can't [ __ ]
get through this whole circuit thing
begin what the [ __ ] complaining every
day that you can't get on so now you're
on you're complaining that you're out
did you get enough air time today what
do you want to say if I call in I have
an agenda you know like I have a comment
I have this for that Jeff calls up and
sits there waiting for you to pick up
and go Jeff how are you doing you guys
talked to Jeff and explained it well
Eric why did you make your point about
that Jeff calls in and doesn't have
something to say go ahead and teach him
[Music]
hung up well now he after the show he'll
call Mary Ann if she got on and he
[ __ ] at her like how the hell are you
[Music]
going through this weeks and weeks and
weeks he has things to say when he's
talking to me and then
[ __ ] just doesn't say anything with
him he's calling me and slamming the
phone in my face
one thing I'll say about Bobo
he calls in he doesn't complain you know
what I'm saying I have my notes my list
of questions whether they're good or not
I have an agenda well Jeff does is
complain and then he hangs up on the
host that's an embarrassment and that's
a direct ridicule to you
okay well I'll tell you what Bob oh you
make a good point I put the guy on and
he just hung up on me by the way Bobo
and Mary Ann they are not back on good
terms I know that Mary Ann can't stand
Bobo she thinks he's a phony today I
wonder warn people not to wear bandanas
I just found this out that it's going to
exasperate the problem what is it going
to do to the problem it's going to
exasperate the problem exactly to do
exasperate yes no exacerbate why that's
what I said
Mary Ann what is it he's got to say
agenda a band dad it doesn't walk he's
so annoying how I can't [ __ ] stand
him anymore
oh yeah well yeah miss flabbergasting
the problem